ALLEN ARCHULETA ATKINS BAY
PACKERS PORCHES BRADFORD
CABALLERO CORTES E. BALLI DODD
DORADO EGGMAN GLAZER GONZALEZ
GROSS HERTZBERG WEST SO- TADO
JONES KAMLAGER LAYERED. LEYVA
LIMONIUM WIRE MELENDEZ MEN
NEWMAN NIELSEN PATROL BOAT PAN
PORTANTINO ALL RUBIO SKINNER
STERN AMBERG BY CASKEY WIENER
WELL. MEMBERS OF A QUORUM IS
PRESENT. WITH THE MEMBERS AND
OUR GUESTS BEYOND THE RAIL AND
IN THE GALLERY PLEASE RISE- WE
WILL BE LED IN PRAYER THIS
AFTERNOON BY SENATOR LEYVA.
AFTER WHICH PLEASE REMAIN
STANDING WE WILL BE LED IN THE
PLEDGE OF ALLEGIANCE TO THE FLAG
BY SENATOR ALAN. THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT GOOD MORNING MEMBERS.
A GOOD AFTERNOON THE BOOK OF
PROVERBS FOUR TWO THREE SAYS
ABOVE ALL ELSE GUARD YOUR HEART
FOR EVERYTHING ELSE FLOWS FROM
IT. CREATOR GOD GIVE US A HEART
LIKE YOURS THAT INSPIRES US TO
LOVE WITHOUT RESERVATION TO STEP
OUT IN COURAGEOUS SERVICE TO ONE
ANOTHER. AND NEVER TO DIG UP IN
DOUBT WHAT WE HAVE PLANTED IN
FAITH. FORTIFY US WITH YOUR
GRACE TO SPEAK KINDLY TO KEEP
OUR ACTIONS ON THE UPSWING. AND
REFUSED TO ALLOW ANY
DISCOURAGEMENT TO INFILTRATE OUR
SPIRITS. GRACIOUS GOD LET YOUR
LIGHT SHINE THROUGH THE CLASS
CRACKS AND SPLINTERS OF THE LESS
THAN PERFECT PORTIONS OF OUR
HEARTS. MAY WE FORGIVE OURSELVES
OUR IMPERFECTIONS AND IN
RESPONSE RETURN COMPASSIONATE
LOVE AND FORGIVENESS TO OTHERS.
AMEN MEMBERS HAPPY VALENTINE'S
DAY WE CELEBRATE. THE GREAT
VICTORY OF THE LOS ANGELES RAMS.
AND TOGETHER WE RECITE OUR
PLEDGE ALLEGIANCE TO OUR
NATION'S FLAG. I PLEDGE
ALLEGIANCE TO. OUR ALL. STRONG.
MESSAGES FROM THE GOVERNOR WILL
BE DEEMED READ MESSAGES FROM THE
ASSEMBLY WILL BE DEEMED READ.
REPORTS OF COMMITTEES WILL BE
DEEMED READ AND AMENDMENTS
ADOPTED MEMBERS ARE GOING TO
MOVE ON TO MOTIONS RESOLUTIONS
AND NOTICES. WITHOUT OBJECTION
THE SENATE JOURNALS FOR THE WEEK
OF FEBRUARY SEVENTH THROUGH
FEBRUARY TENTH TWO TWENTY TWENTY
TWO WILL BE APPROVED AS
CORRECTED BY THE MINUTE CLERK.
MEMBERS ARE ON MOTIONS
RESOLUTIONS AND NOTICES. SENATOR
MELENDEZ. YEAH YEAH OKAY SENATOR
MELENDEZ THE FORGERS. THANK YOU
SO MUCH MADAM PRESIDENT SENATORS
PURSUANT TO SENATE RULE TWENTY
EIGHT I AM MAKING A MOTION TO
WITHDRAW AS SIERRA FIVE FROM THE
SENATE GOVERNMENTAL ORGANIZATION
COMMITTEE AND BROUGHT TO THE
SENATE FLOOR SO THAT WE CAN HAVE
A FULL AND VIGOROUS DEBATE. IT
HAS BEEN SEVEN HUNDRED AND
TWELVE DAYS NOW SINCE THE
GOVERNOR'S DECLARED STATE OF
EMERGENCY. FOUR HUNDRED AND
TWENTY NINE DAYS SINCE I FIRST
INTRODUCED THIS RESOLUTION.
CENTERS I WOULD URGE YOU TO
CONSIDER SUPPORTING THIS MOTION
SO THAT WE CAN. APPROPRIATELY
DEBATE S. C. R. FIVE AND SHOW TO
SHOW THE VOTERS THAT WE ARE
INDEED A DELIBERATIVE BODY EVERY
BILL SHOULD GET AHEARING EVERY
OTHER COVERED RELATED BILL HAS
RECEIVED THE HEARING EXCEPT FOR
A SIERRA FIVE. SO I WOULD ASK
THAT YOU SUPPORT AT LEAST THE
DEBATE OF SCR BAR YOU DON'T HAVE
TO VOTE FOR IT YOU CAN VOTE
AGAINST IT. BUT AT LEAST SHOW
WHETHER YOU'RE FOR OR AGAINST
WITH THAT I ASK FOR YOUR I DON'T
. THANK YOU VERY MUCH SENATE
MCGUIRE.THANK YOU SO MUCH
MATTER PRESENT WOULD
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR A NO VOTE.
CENTER MELENDEZ AFTER AN AYE
VOTE SENATOR MCGUIRE US FOR A NO
VOTE PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. ALLEN
NO ARCHULETA NO ATKINS NO BATES
AYE BAKER. NO FOR JUST. BRADFORD
NO CABALLERO NO CORTES HE NO
DALLY. DODD NO TORONTO NO EGGMAN
NO GLAZER. NO GONZALEZ GROVE. I
HERTZBERG. NO WAY PHONE. HURTADO
NO JONES HI KAMLAGER. NO LAYERED
NO LEYVA NO LIMÓN. MCGUIRE NO
MELENDEZ I MEN NO NEWMAN. NO
NIELSEN HI- TELEVOTE HI PAN NO
PORTANTINO NO ROTH NO RUBIO. NO
SKINNER NO STERN. NO I'M BURKE
NO WHITE HOUSE SKI NO WIENER.
WILK HI PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS PORGES DALLY. GONZALEZ
WESTERN LIMON WIENER. OKAY I
SEVEN KNOWS TWENTY SEVEN THE
MOTION FAILS MEMBERS ARE GOING
TO MOVE ON TO INTRODUCTION AND
FIRST READING OF BILLS WHICH
WILL BE DEEMED READ MOVING ON TO
THE CONSIDERATION OF THE DAILY
FILE SENATE THIRD READING FILE
ITEM NUMBER SEVEN SENATOR GROWTH. SENATOR GROVER IS READY MADAM
SECRETARY PLEASE READ. SENATE
RESOLUTION SIXTY FIVE BY SENATOR
GROWTH RELATIVE TO NATIONAL
HUMAN TRAFFICKING AWARENESS
MONTH. CENTER GROVE THE FLOOR IS
YOURS. THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT- TODAY I RISE TO
PRESENT S. C. R. SIXTY FIVE
WHICH COMMEMORATES JANUARY TO
TWENTY TWENTY TWO AS HUMAN
TRAFFICKING AWARENESS MONTH IT'S
IMPORTANT THAT WE CONTINUE TO
RECOGNIZE THE HORRENDOUS ACT OF
HUMAN TRAFFICKING AND THE EFFECT
THAT IT HAS ALL OVER IN EACH ONE
OF OUR COMMUNITIES. THE
INTERNATIONAL LABOR ORGANIZATION
ESTIMATES OVER THE LAST DECADE
THAT THERE WERE ALMOST FORTY
MILLION HUMAN TRAFFICKING
VICTIMS WORLDWIDE. 81% WERE
TRAPPED IN FORCED LABOUR AND A
TOTAL OF 25% WERE CHILDREN AND
75% WERE WOMEN AND GIRLS. LET
THAT SINK IN FOR JUST A MINUTE
COLLEAGUES WE'RE TALKING ABOUT
MILLIONS OF LITTLE BOYS AND
LITTLE GIRLS WHO ARE VICTIMS OF
HUMAN TRAFFICKING. DUE TO
CALIFORNIA'S EXTENSIVE
INTERNATIONAL BORDER SIGNIFICAN
IMMIGRANT POPULATION IN MAJOR
AIRPORTS AND HARBORS THE STATUS.
THE STATE IS A HOTBED FOR HUMAN
TRAFFICKING. BECAUSE OF THIS
LOCAL STATE AND FEDERAL LAW
ENFORCEMENT AGENCIES CONTINUE TO
WORK TIRELESSLY. TO END HUMAN
TRAFFICKING AND PROTECT OUR MOST
VULNERABLE PLEASE JOIN ME IN
SUPPORTING THIS YEAR SIXTY FIVE
AND GIVE A VOICE TO THE MILLIONS
OF VICTIMS THAT HAVE SUFFERED
FROM THIS HORRIFIC ABUSE. WE
MUST FIGHT TO PROTECT VICTIMS
STRENGTHEN PREVENTION AND
INCREASE THE PROSECUTION OF
THOSE WHO BUY AND SELL HUMAN
BEANS I WOULD APPRECIATE YOUR
AYE VOTE. MEMBERS IS THERE ANY
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON THIS
ITEM. ANY DISCUSSION OR DEBATE.
THING THEN PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
. ALLEN HI ARCHULETA HI ATKINS
AYE BATES AYE BAKER I PORCHES
BRADFORD FIVE CABALLERO I
PROTECTING HI DALY AYE DODD. I
TO RUSSELL FIVE EGGMAN FIVE
GLAZER HI GONZALEZ GROSS HI
HERTZBERG HI WESTERN. BRITTONUM
I JONES I KAMLAGER I LAYERED I
LEYVA HI LIMÓN. MCGUIRE AYE
MELENDEZ AYE MIN HI NEWMAN AYE
NIELSEN AYE A SHOW OF AYE PAN
AYE PORTANTINO. FIVE ROTH AYE
RUBIO. I SKINNER. I STERN AYE
NUMBER HI WHITE HOUSE SKI I
WIENER. WILK HI. PLEASE CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS. PORGES GONZALEZ
WESTERN LIMON. WIENER. FIVE
THIRTY FIVE NO ZERO THE
RESOLUTION THE RESOLUTION IS
ADOPTED MEMBERS ARE GOING TO
MOVE ON TO ASSEMBLY THIRD
READING BUT I WANT TO REMIND YOU
THAT IF TO TAKE YOUR
CONVERSATIONS OFF THE FLOOR
BECAUSE THEY'RE DISTRACTING
APPEAR I'M GONNA TAKE UP FILE
ITEM NUMBER EIGHT SENATOR UMBERG
IS READY MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE
READ. ASSEMBLY BILL SIX SIX SIX
FIVE ASSEMBLY MEMBER PERKS SILVA
AN ACT RELATING TO SUBSTANCE
ABUSE CENTER I'M VERY THE
FORAGERS THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT AND COLLEAGUES-
MEMBERS OF THE PRICE WE TWO
POINT SEVEN MILLION CALIFORNIANS
HAD A DIAGNOSABLE. SUBSTANCE
ABUSE DISORDER IN THE PAST YEAR
AND THE WORK FORCE TO ADDRESS
THAT ISSUE IS WOEFULLY BOTH.
UNDER FUNDED AND REPRESENTED AB
SIX SIX SIX TAKES CRITICAL STEPS
TO ADDRESS THE SHORTAGE AND LACK
OF DIVERSITY WITH THE STATE'S
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH. WORKFORCE BY
REQUIRING THE DEPARTMENT OF
HEALTH CARE SERVICES TO DEVELOP
A STATEWIDE. SUBSTANCE ABUSE
DISORDER WORKFORCE NEEDS
ASSESSMENT AND DETERMINE AREAS
TO ENTRY S. BABY SIX SIX SIX
WOULD AUTHORIZE THE DEPARTMENT
TO IMPLEMENT. THE SUBSTANCE
ABUSE WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT
PROGRAMMING THAT INCLUDES
STIPENDS FOR TUITION
REIMBURSEMENTS STUDENTS TO
COMPLETE. COURSEWORK AND
PROGRAMS RELATED S. U. DIS BILL
HAS UNANIMOUS BIPARTISAN SUPPORT
I URGE NIVAL. IS THERE ANY
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE. ANY
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE. SINGMAN
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. ALLEN FIVE
ARCHULETA AYE ATKINS AYE BATES
AYE BACKER AYE FORGES. BRADFORD
I HAVE. AYE PROTESTING AYE DALLY
I DODD I THE RUSSELL HI EGGMAN
AYE GLAZER I GONZALEZ. GROVE I
HERTZBERG AYE HUESO. HER TADO I
JONES I KAMLAGER. FIVE LAYERED I
LEYVA AYE LIMÓN. MCGUIRE AYE
MELENDEZ AYE MIN AYE NEWMAN AYE
NIELSEN BY A SHOW OF BOTH. I CAN
I PORTANTINO HI ROTH AYE RUBIO I
SKINNER. I STERN AYE NUMBER I
LIKE HOW SKI I WIENER WILK. HI
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS.
PORGES GONZALEZ WESSEL LIMON
WIENER. FIVE THIRTY FIVE NO ZERO
THE MEASURE PASSESMOVING ON TO
FILE ITEM NUMBER NINE SENATOR
DODD HE'S READY PLEASE READ.
ASSEMBLY CONCURRENT RESOLUTION
ONE TWELVE BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER
GRAYSON RELATIVE TO POSITIVE
PARENTING AWARENESS MONTH CENTER
DOG FOR YEARS THANK YOU BETTER
PRESIDENT COLLEAGUES I RISE
TODAY TO PRESENT ACR ONE TWELVE
WHICH WOULD DECLARE JANUARY IS
POSITIVE PARENTING AWARENESS
MONTH. THAT RECOGNIZES JANUARY
TWENTY TWENTY TWO THAT'S
POSITIVE PARENTING AWARENESS
MONTH. THE POSITIVE PARENTING
APPROACH IMPLEMENTED BY LOCAL
AGENCIES THROUGHOUT THE STATE IS
BASED ON COLLECTIVE WISDOM AND
EVIDENCE ABOUT THE SKILLS IT'S
SUPPORT CHILDREN NEED TO BECOME
HAPPY HEALTHY CONFIDENT IN
INDEPENDENT HUMAN BEINGS. WHEN
CHILDREN GROW UP IN A POSITIVE
LOVING AND SAFE ENVIRONMENT WITH
CLEAR AN CONSISTENT BOUNDARIES
AND LIMITS THEIR BRAINS ARE
PRIMED TO LEARN IN SCHOOL GET
ALONG WITH OTHERS AND SUCCEED AS
ADULTS IN FUTURE RELATIONSHIPS
AND CAREERS. ALTHOUGH APPARENTLY
IS A NONSTOP JOB THE DESERVES
RECOGNITION EVERY DAY OF THE
YEAR ACR ONE TWELVE SPECIFIC
HIGHLIGHTS THE VALUE A POSITIVE
PARENTING IN IMPORTANCE FOR
PARENTS AND CAREGIVERS TO
DEVELOP WARM NURTURING
RELATIONSHIPS WITH THEIR
CHILDREN AND FOR THEM TO BECOME
MORE CONFIDENT IS PERRANCE. IN
THEMSELVES THANK YOU FOR YOUR
ATTENTION RECOGNITION OF
POSITIVE PARENTING AWARENESS.
MONTH AND REQUEST YOUR AYE VOTE.
IS THERE ANY DISCUSS OR DEBATE
ON THE SIDE. ANY DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE. SEEING NONE PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL. ALLEN. FIVE ARCHULETA
AYE ATKINS AYE BATES. BAKER HI
FORTUS BRADFORD AYE CABALLERO
AYE PROTESTING AYE DALY I DODD.
I TORONTO I EGGMAN AYE GLAZER I
GONZALEZ. GROSS. GROSS I
HERTZBERG HI WITH SO. HURTADO I
JONES HI KAMLAGER. I LAYERED. I
LEYVA AYE MON AYE MCGUIRE.
MELENDEZ AYE MIN AYE NEWMAN AYE
NIELSEN. BUT CHAO NIELSEN I ARE
TROUBLED BY PAN. I PORTANTINO I
ROTH AYE RUBIO I SKINNER I STERN
HI NUMBER I LIKE OWSKI I WIENER
WELL. HI PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS BATES I. GORGEOUS
GONZALEZ WESO. MCGUIRE I WIENER
. FIVE THIRTY SIX NOSEY ZERO THE
MEASURE PASSES MEMBERS ARE GONNA
MOVE ON TO FILE ITEM NUMBER
THIRTEEN SENATOR KAMLAGER. SHE
IS PREPARED PLEASE READ ASSEMBLY
CONCURRENT RESOLUTION ONE OH
FOUR BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER HOLDEN
RELATIVE TO A SISTER STATE
RELATIONSHIP WITH CLINTON
PAKISTAN. CENTER KAMLAGER THE
FLOOR'S YOURS THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT I AM PROUD TO PRESENT
ACR ONE OH FOUR WHICH CREATES A
SISTER STATE RELATIONSHIP WITH
THE PROVINCE OF PUNJAB PAKISTAN
AND THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA THIS
RESOLUTION. ESTABLISHES A FORMAL
SISTER STATE RELATIONSHIP THAT
WOULD PROMOTE MULTI DIMENSIONAL
COLLABORATION ALLOWING FOR
MUTUAL TRADE AND COMMERCE AN
INCREASE THE POTENTIAL FOR
CULTURAL RELATIONS. ACR ONE OH
FOUR IS A FORMAL DECLARATION
THAT ENCOURAGES COOPERATION.
THIS MUTUALLY BENEFICIAL
RELATIONSHIP WILL ELEVATE THE
SIMILARITIES AND COMMONALITIES
BETWEEN PUNE JOB AND CALIFORNIA
PUNJAB CAPITAL LAHORE IS A
CULTURAL HISTORICAL ECONOMIC AND
COSMOPOLITAN CENTER OF PAKISTAN
WHERE THE COUNTRY'S CINEMA
INDUSTRY AND MUCH OF ITS FASHION
INDUSTRY ARE BASED MUCH LIKE THE
GREAT LOS ANGELES IN OUR STATE.
HOME OF THE CHAMPIONS THE RAMS.
LIKE CALIFORNIA PUNJAB IS ALSO
CONSIDERED THE BREADBASKET OF
PAKISTAN WHERE AGRICULTURE PLAYS
A SIGNIFICANT ROLE IN THE
ECONOMY MUCH. NOW I JUST SAID
THAT SO AMAZING YES WE HAVE OVER
TWO HUNDRED AND FIFTY THOUSAND
PUNE JABI AMERICANS IN
CALIFORNIA IN A LARGE PERCENTAGE
OF THOSE LIVING IN SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA IN THE HEART OF LOS
ANGELES THE CONSULATE GENERAL OF
PAKISTAN IN LOS ANGELES IS
SUPPORTIVE OF THIS RESOLUTION AS
ARE SO MANY ACTIVISTS ACROSS THE
STATE WHO SEE THESE MOMENTS. AS
OPPORTUNITIES TO CONTINUE TO
EDUCATE US ON HOW WE CAN WORK
TOGETHER TO BUILD SISTER STATE
RELATIONSHIP THAT HONOR AND
CELEBRATE CULTURAL DIVERSITY
ADVANCEMENT AND COLLABORATION I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOU I VOTE
ON A C. R. ONE O. FOUR. SENATOR
ALAN. A QUESTION THE OTHER. WILL
YOU ACCEPT THE QUESTION. YES HE
WELL SENATOR WHOSE HOUSE. RAMS
HOUSE. I ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE ON
EACH YEAR ONE OF FOUR. IS THERE
ANY FURTHER DISCUSSION OR DEBATE
ON THE MERITS OF THE BILL. RIGHT. YOU MEET YOU MAKE INCLUDE
SENATOR KAMLAGER THANK YOU SO
MUCH FOR THAT QUESTION
TANGENTIAL AS IT WAS BUT I THANK
YOU FOR IT I WOULD JUST
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE VOTE
ON ACR ONE ZERO FOUR. MADAM
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ALLEN AYE ARCHULETA AYE ATKINS
AYE BATES AYE BAKER. I PORCHES
BRADFORD AYE CABALLERO AYE
PROTESTING AYE TALLY AYE DODD.
HI TORONTO I EGGMAN AYE GLAZER I
GONZALEZ GROVE I HERTZBERG AYE
WESTERN. HURTADO I JONES FIVE
KAMLAGER I LAYERED AYE LEYVA AYE
LIMÓN AYE MCGUIRE HI MELENDEZ
FIVE MILLION FIVE NEWMAN AYE
NIELSEN I A TROUBLED I CAN. I
PORTANTINO AYE ROTH AYE RUBIO
AYE SKINNER. I STERN I NUMBER
ALL RIGHT HI MY CASTING AYE
WIENER. WELL HI PLEASE CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS. PORGES GONZALEZ
WESO. WIENER I THIRTY SIX NO
ZERO THE RESOLUTION IS ADOPTED.
MEMBERS ARE GOING TO MOVE BACK
TO PRIVILEGES OF THE FLOOR
SENATOR DRAWS SO. THANK YOU
MADAM PRESIDENT I RISE WITH
GREAT PRIDE- TO CONGRATULATE THE
LOS ANGELES RAMS OF FOR THEIR
VICTORY AS A SUPER BOWL
CHAMPIONS OF TWENTY TWENTY TWO.
I RISE AS THE SENATOR OF
CALIFORNIA. BECAUSE I THINK THAT
ALL OF US WOULD BE PROUD. TO
SHARE IN THATIN THAT VICTORY I
ALSO RISE TO SAY THAT THIS IS A
VICTORY NOT ONLY FOR THE
FOOTBALL TEAMS THEMSELVES FOR
THE RAMS THEMSELVES. BUT ALSO
BECAUSE OF THE ECONOMIC
DEVELOPMENT THAT ARE BROUGHT TO
THE COMMUNITY- EXTRAORDINARY
SMALL BUSINESS OUTREACH AND-
SHARING OF THE PROSPERITY. AND
ALSO OF WHICH GOT SOME ATTENTION
IN THE MEDIA IS THE BEST AND
STRONGEST CONTRIBUTION TO OUR
COMMUNITY AND TO OUR STATE. AND
THAT IS THE CREATION OF GOOD
JOBS JUST TWO DAYS BEFORE THE
GAME- AN AGREEMENT WAS REACHED
WITH THE CONCESSION WORKERS
WHERE. DIRT DISHWASHERS WILL GO
AS HIGH AS THIRTY DOLLARS AN
HOUR DURING THE TERM OF THE
COLLECTIVE BARGAINING AGREEMENT
WITH PENSION AND HEALTH BENEFITS
SO THIS WAS A VICTORY FOR THE
ENTIRE COMMUNITY THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. THANK YOU FOR THAT
RECOGNIZE RECOGNITION SAYING
THIS IS REALLY. AMERICA WHILE I
WAS GOING TO SAY NO MY CORRUPT
SENATOR BRADFORD. THANK YOU
MADAM PRESIDENT I JUST WANT TO
ECHO OF THE COMMENTS THAT MY
COLLEAGUE FROM EAST LOS ANGELES
STATED. AND AS INDIVIDUAL WHO
REPRESENTS INGLEWOOD I'VE SEEN A
TREMENDOUS UPTICK AND COMMUNITY
PRIDE BUT ALSO ECONOMIC
PROSPERITY AND OPPORTUNITY THIS
IS PAST WEEKEND WE WERE ABLE TO
PARTICIPATE. A WITH A LOT OF
LOCAL SMALL BUSINESSES WHO HAVE
RECEIVED GRANTS OVER THE LAST
COUPLE OF MONTHS SIMPLY BECAUSE
OF. WHAT WAS HAPPENING WITH THE
SUPER BOWL AND SO IT HAS HAD A
TREMENDOUS IMPACT BUT AS STATED
ALSO IT'S BROUGHT GREATER
AWARENESS TO THE IMPORTANCE OF.
ORGANIZED LABOR AND THE ROLE
THAT THEY PLAY NOT ONLY IN
BUILDING THAT STADIUM BUT
HELPING TO MAINTAIN AND GROW
ITSELF I TOO WANT TO
CONGRATULATE THE INGLEWOOD
ROUNDS FOR A GREAT YEAR AND A
GREAT. VICTORY SENATOR RUBIO.
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT I JUST
ALSO WANT TO ADD MY VOICE TO THE
COMMISSARY STATED HERE BUT IN
PARTICULAR I DID SEE A LOT OF
FOCUS ON TRYING TO ELEVATE WOMEN
WOMEN OF COLOR ARE MINORITY
OWNED BUSINESSES IN PARTICULAR
WOMEN ON AND SO I'M VERY
THANKFUL FOR THAT AND FOR
EVERYTHING THAT THEY BROUGHT TO
LOS ANGELES IN PARTICULAR I
DON'T THINK OF THAT THE GAME
ITSELF BUT ALL THE BUSINESSES
THAT ARE AROUND THE STADIUM ALSO
BENEFITED IN A BIG WAY SO WE'RE
VERY HAPPY AND DIAGRAMS. THANK
YOU. SENATOR KAMLAGER. THANK YOU
I TO WANT TO CONGRATULATE THE
WORLD CHAMPIONS THE LOS ANGELES
RAMS FOR THEIR VICTORY AND ON
WEDNESDAY WHILE WE WILL BE HERE
THEY WILL ACTUALLY BE- THE
HAVING THEIR OPPORTUNITY TO
PARTICIPATE IN THE PARADE
THROUGHOUT THE CITY STARTING IN
THE THIRTY S. SENATE DISTRICT
YOU KNOW I HAD THE GOOD FORTUNE
OF BEING PART OF AN EVENT ON
SATURDAY BEFORE THE GAME DAY
WITH LOCAL ELEVEN UNITE HERE
CELEBRATING THE RATIFICATION OF
AN AGREEMENT WITH SO FIVE
STADIUM SO THAT THAT STADIUM IS
A 100% UNION. AND WHEN WE ARE
FIGHTING ON THIS FLOOR FOR
INVESTMENTS INTO COMMUNITIES AND
FOR GOOD PAYING UNION CAREERS IT
IS BECAUSE WE WANT TO SEE THOSE
KINDS OF DAYS HAPPEN WHERE YOU
HAVE FOLKS ACROSS A GENDER AND
ETHNIC SPECTRUM. EXCITED ABOUT
PARTNERING WITH AN EMPLOYER.
THAT SEES THEM AND DIGNIFIED AS
THEIR WORK. I ALSO WANT TO SAY.
HOW EVENTS LIKE THIS. HAVE AN
EXPONENTIAL IMPACT ON LOCAL
ECONOMIES AND ONE OF THE THINGS
IT ALSO HAS AN IMPACT ON HIS ON
TRANSPORTATION SO AS WE ARE
THINKING ABOUT. ISSUES THAT WE
SHOULD BE ADDRESSING THIS YEAR I
HOPE THAT WE WILL PAY ATTENTION
TO THE TRANSPORTATION NEEDS
ACROSS THE STATE BUT
SPECIFICALLY THOSE THAT CENTER
AROUND THESE HUBS OF ECONOMIC
ACTIVITY LIKE THE SURPRISE
STADIUM SO THAT WE CAN PUSH
FORWARD TO MAKE ALL KINDS OF
GAME DAYS LIKE WE SAW SUNDAY.
EXCITING. FOR THAT'S ALL THANK
YOU. THANK YOU SO MUCH SO IF- IF
I COULD ASK YOU ALL TO GIVE A
SHOW OF SUPPORT FOR THE LA RAMS
CONGRATULATIONS ON A VICTORY JOB
WELL DONE. SAN SO IF THERE IS NO
OTHER BUSINESS SENATOR RECKONS
THE DESK IT'S CLEAR. SENATE
PRESIDENT THANK YOU SO MUCH- WE
ARE THRILLED TO BE TOGETHER
CELEBRATING VALENTINE'S DAY. I
HOPE YOU ALL MANAGED TO FIND A
WAY DO NOT FORGET TO CALL YOUR
LOVED ONES IF YOU HAVEN'T
ALREADY TAKING CARE OF THAT
PLEASE DO. AND WITH THAT IT WILL
BE A LONG WEEK OUR NEXT FLOOR
SESSION IS SCHEDULED FOR FRIDAY
FEBRUARY EIGHTEENTH TWENTY
TWENTY TWO AT NINE AM THANK YOU
. THE SENATE WILL BE IN RECESS
UNTIL THREE THIRTY AT WHICH TIME
THE ADJOURNMENT MOTION WILL BE
MADE WE WILL RECONVENE FRIDAY AT
NINE AM.